washington dc august 31st 2021 hours
after the last u.s soldiers leave
afghanistan president joe biden declares
the war over last night in kabul
the united states ended 20 years of war
in afghanistan
the longest war in american history
a war that killed three and a half
thousand u.s and allied soldiers
66 000 afghan military and police
personnel 51 000 taliban fighters and
more than 47 000 civilians
in the same speech however biden
announces that the fight against
terrorism in afghanistan and other
countries will continue
we have what's called over the horizon
capabilities which means we can strike
terrorists and targets without american
boots on the ground or very few if
needed
over the horizon capabilities what
exactly does this mean is going to
continue its highly controversial drone
program in afghanistan and if so is the
war really over
sort of it depends on what you mean by
over
biden has to some extent spoken out of
both sides of his mouth on this of where
he has said things like uh people who
are 20 years old americans who are 20
years old have never known a nation at
peace and now they will and that's not
really true the um things like because
then at the other at the same time he
says things like uh the united states
will continue using over the horizon
capacity in afghanistan and so if the
united states is going to be
actively trying to search for and kill
people in afghanistan that means the us
is kind of at war there so in in recent
years with the
uh reliance increasing reliance on uh
air power it's been very easy for
american presidents to
uh either indicate that we do not have
uh a troop presence in a country or
declare that a war is over um and almost
using
drones or air power as kind of a
subterfuge i think
the use of drones then uh has this sort
of antiseptic quality
um that
is it creates kind of this perception
that there is no combat just because u.s
uh personnel are not dying and what we
saw with the recent drone strike a week
or two ago
is that uh civilians were killed is
difficult to answer at the moment i mean
we saw the us withdrawal but what we
also saw were two american drone strikes
that took place after
the isis attack at kabul airport
the aftermath of a us drone strike
carried out following the isk suicide
bombing outside kabu airport
the strike was intended to target an isk
facilitator
but the pentagon later admitted that it
killed only civilians 10 innocent people
seven of them children we now had
this
extraordinary case that a drone strike
took place in the middle of the city and
it just killed civilians and many people
are now reacting and wondering
what happened in the past if you visit
the certain areas that have been
affected by this kind of warfare during
the last two decades afghan villages you
will always hear the same people
explained and described how american
drones terrorized them how these drones
killed
a lot of farmers a lot of cab drivers a
lot of other laborers instead of taliban
militants or al-qaeda militants
over the course of the 20-year war in
afghanistan four different u.s
administrations have carried out several
thousand drone strikes
starting with what is believed to be the
first ever drone strike in history in
2001.
it missed its target taliban founder
mullah omar
he died of natural causes more than a
decade later
the exact number of u.s drone strikes in
afghanistan or elsewhere is unknown
in 2016 the obama administration
introduced a rule requiring an annual
public report on drone strikes including
civilian deaths
but this did not include afghanistan
only strikes on targets outside of war
zones in pakistan somalia and yemen
obama's successor donald trump later
revoked the executive order
information on drone strikes in
afghanistan only became public through
whistleblower daniel hale hale is a
former u.s air force intelligence
analyst
in 2014 after leaving the air force he
leaked 17 classified documents detailing
civilian casualties some of the
documents show that during one
five-month stretch of an operation in
afghanistan ninety percent of those
killed were not the intended targets
in july 2021 halo was sentenced to 45
months in prison for the leak
the uk-based bureau of investigative
journalism documented u.s drone strikes
in afghanistan between 2015 and 2019
showing an increase in their use there
during the trump presidency
all recent u.s presidents have used
drone strikes after taking office the
biden administration may no longer
consider afghanistan an active war zone
but that doesn't mean it won't imply
drones there somalia and also yemen are
the two countries that will likely be
the model for continuing drone strikes
in afghanistan i would expect the drone
program to continue because
while various presidents have campaigns
with different perspectives on it they
get into office and then all seem to
continue it which suggests that there is
classified intelligence showing that the
us government thinks that these are
unbalanced successful
but drone warfare remains controversial
many have argued that drone strikes
might create more terrorists than they
kill
you cannot
neutralize terrorism like this and
actually the people who are affected by
it they don't defer between terrorism
spread by the taliban or terrorism from
the skies spread by the drones but what
the research shows is that
the drone strikes are successful at
reducing terrorist groups capacity the
overall benefits
you know just as a crude cost benefit
analysis the overall benefits of it i
think are
higher than the downsides i think
anticipated military gain
is problematic
even if that's what stipulated
international law because we can always
kind of justify
a target
through the lens or through the
justification that this
this anticipated military gain
is so high that it will offset
the
uh loss to civilians no military gains
were made in the attack on the ahmadi
family
the august 29 strike points to some of
the obstacles the us drone campaign
would face in afghanistan now that the
taliban are back in power the pentagon
said the decision to strike was taken in
an earnest belief of an imminent threat
to american forces that believe turned
out to be unfounded the head of u.s
central command called it a tragic
mistake
the united states is going to find it is
going to be considerably harder because
without all of the american forces on
the ground or non-military personnel as
well the united states is not going to
have as good intelligence of afghanistan
and we could see some of this of some of
the problems potentially with the final
u.s drone strike in afghanistan before
withdrawing that's also the big question
where will the next american drones
probably start to bomb targets in
afghanistan because they are not within
the country anymore so will they use
pakistan will they use uzbekistan will
they use tajikistan
we don't know that in the past for
example when the war on terror started
the americans worked with uzbekistan
and some drones started from there
you have to either fly over iran which
is a no
have to fly over pakistan which is
complicated or have to fly over the
caucasus in the caspian sea and then
some combination either turkmenistan or
uzbekistan and some combination of the
countries kazakhstan into uzbekistan
that are north of afghanistan and that
means a variety of complicated
relationships with
complicated relations and diplomacy with
those countries to get the permission
and it may sound unlikely but there
could be cooperation with the taliban
too especially when it comes to fighting
common enemies like the so-called
islamic state the taliban will continue
fighting isis the united states wants to
fight isis and when it comes to things
like this when it comes to war countries
tend to prioritize interests over
friendships so the united states and the
taliban might have fought a long war
against each other they might disagree
very strongly on some things they might
be adversaries in various regards but if
they have a common enemy they can work
together
afghanistan's newly appointed minister
of the interior surajidin haqqani was
once the target of u.s drone strike
himself
he escaped
it would be a strange turnaround of
events if akani ended up sitting at a
taliban u.s negotiating table deciding
on further u.s drone strikes in
afghanistan